okay so i've always had a bit of a
difficult relationship with self-help
books in the sense that i absolutely
despised them and flat out refused to
read them for the longest time
but over the last two years things have
slightly changed and i've gotten to the
point where there's a few that i would
genuinely recommend that people read so
in this video i wanted to go through a
deep dive of number one why i absolutely
hate most self-help books and still do
number two how i approach them now and
how my mind has slightly changed about
this and number three i'm just going to
go through five self-help books that i
would actually recommend that people
read there's going to be a long rant in
the beginning of the video so if you
just want to skip ahead to the books you
can do so everything will be time
stamped below otherwise let's get
straight into it so when i refer to
self-help books what i'm going to be
referring to in this video are books
that are explicitly written with a goal
of improving one's life making you more
productive making you happier improving
your relationship creating habits and
things like that
these are not the fiction books that
unintentionally do this because i love
fiction self-help books which means that
books that are not written explicitly
for this reason but make me feel this
way i'm talking about those kind of like
pop psychology books that are written to
improve your life now the reasons why i
absolutely think they're awful is
firstly because i think that they are
overwritten most of helpbooks can fit
into a blog post in my opinion literally
no reason for them to be a whole book i
feel as though in a way they're just
expanded on further and further to reach
the quota of making a book because i
feel as though they're making the same
point 15 different times written in
almost the exact same way again and
again and again in the book there is so
much fluff in them and given that the
way that they are written is usually not
very creative and not very great it
doesn't feel as though there's a reason
for things to be this way so for example
if i read some fiction i never feel as
though there's too many words it's a
joyful experience everything is
beautiful i'm happy to read very very
long books however sometimes when i read
pop like psychology and when i read kind
of self-help books very very often i get
the feeling of why are you wasting my
time and i feel so disrespected as a
reader because i'm being told the same
thing the exact same way a hundred
different times so this is one of the
reasons that i feel very strongly that
they are kind of a very inefficient way
to get information the next thing i feel
kind of strongly about is the way that
they interpret science i feel as though
the interpretations of scientific
studies and scientific literature is
quite sus so it's quite suspicious in
these pop psychology books i feel as
though if you look at the actual
resources very often or the same study
will be interpreted in so many different
ways by different writers that it
doesn't make any sense almost they come
to conclusions that are not explicitly
said in the study itself and that are
kind of bending reason and the truth to
some extent that it feels
a bit dubious and also a lot of the
studies that they are relying on
themselves are not that reliable to
start with and then you can write a
whole book based on three or four
scientific studies that are suspicious
to begin with that doesn't make for
great work of literature so that's one
thing that i also don't like a lot the
other thing i don't like about self-help
books is that i feel as though in a way
they are not being honest with me as a
reader and what i mean by this is that
for example when i read a philosophy
book the philosopher very often has a
very very strong stand so a philosopher
might say we no one is alive or trauma
doesn't exist and they take a very
extreme extreme stand somewhere but they
are admitting that this is just their
opinion and it's kind of an intellectual
exercise of okay say this was true why
would it be true or let's explore it
even further or let's find all the
arguments that can support this claim so
it's kind of a intellectual game in a
way between me and the philosopher and
this is why most philosophers i think
stand on very very extreme states and
extreme positions it's it's fun it's
entertaining we all know that this is
just one argument or just one way to
view the picture or just one end of the
scale however what i often see in
self-help books is the same kind of
behavior but it's disguised as being
science so the author will just write
about their experience or like how they
improve their life and then they're
going to bend five studies that will
show and support this and then say oh
but this is the truth this is the
science this is what actually happens
when this isn't necessarily the case so
i feel as though if self-help books were
a bit more open in saying hey this is
what worked for me and obviously this
might not work for you that would be a
lot more helpful than kind of going out
there and saying this is the truth this
is the study that supports that everyone
should be doing this so i feel as though
this lack of communication and
understanding between me and the way the
writers often pitch these self-help
books kind of makes me a bit
uncomfortable in a way that i'm not with
even more strong positions when they are
held in philosophy another huge issue i
have with these books is that very often
they go into the realm of toxic
positivity or on the other side of kind
of really thriving and embracing trauma
and not really wanting to change it
sometimes so i don't like either of
these stands i don't think that you know
once you finish the book there is this
notion of now you can always be
perfectly happy and things will be fine
and you know you're solved you're fixed
just do these things and your life will
be perfect or on the other end saying oh
you know obviously you've been through
so much trauma and you should just
embrace this and this is your strength
and all these different different ways
that i think are just at least with me
don't resonate with the way that i see
the world and the way that i see my life
so i find these kind of a bit
frustrating when i read them and see
them in books i feel as though very
often rigid formulas that guarantee
success in a certain way when they're
not applicable to you can't end up
making you feel almost worse in a way or
just make the book pointless so i feel
as though this is a big issue that i
have with these books in general and to
boil these all down for me i think my
issue with self-help books in principle
is that they are teaching me what to
think rather than how to think and i
think this is a very important
distinction that i make in books in
general when i read kind of the summary
of a book or when i read the first few
pages i'm very attuned to the tone of
the author is it telling me what to
think and what to do or is it telling me
how to think and how to view my life and
how to view things in general because i
will always go for a book that will
teach me how to think very often these
tend to be fiction books these are not
self-help books but
sometimes there are some health
self-help books that will teach me how
to think rather than what i should be
doing and what i should be thinking
which i think is just very pointless i
don't agree with this in general now
while i still very much hold all of
these opinions very strongly i have some
views on how self-help books can
actually be helpful in some situations
the first reason is that well-written
self-help books will give me clarity and
understanding of that kind of mess and
state of being that is my inside that i
sometimes don't have access to and this
is especially important when it comes to
conversations with other people i think
self-help books that are written very
well with effective frameworks can give
language and terms and names to things
that i don't know how to describe
otherwise i think we are so limited in
the amount of language insight and
understanding and vocabulary that we are
given growing up in terms of our
internal state of being i have so many
words to describe the world around me
the objects around me when it comes to
myself i just have a very limited amount
of things i can say i'm sad or happy or
hurt or distressed or anxious but these
are very vague and non-specific to
different situations however when you
read a self-help book it really provides
you good language so for example instead
of telling someone in my life that oh
i'm just feeling really bad or this is
making me very anxious i can say
actually what you just did triggered
some anxious attachment on my end and we
will both immediately know what is going
on in my state in a way that captures it
so so well and is so specific and it's
just incredible i often imagine what it
would be like if i had to describe
everything in my life the way i need to
describe my emotions so if i just had to
go every time i need to talk about a
saucepan i would be you know that round
thing that you put on a stove and you
put things inside it that's actually
quite deep and sometimes has a handle
that would be so difficult to go around
life having to describe everything this
way and yet when it comes to our
emotions every time i need to say
something i need to have a safe space
and a safe situation and a lot of time
and someone's full attention to be able
to elaborate exactly what i'm feeling
while with self-help books very often
once they give you these frameworks it's
very easy to say immediately this is
what i'm feeling this is what's being
triggered and we immediately know what's
going on both me on my end for my
internal state and also the other person
for understanding my eternal state so i
think this is just brilliant brilliant
brilliant when it comes to self-help
books and the second thing i love about
them and i have to accept this is that
at the end of the day they're just
trying to do a good thing like these
authors are out there trying to make
people happier trying to make people
feel better so that's something i can
obviously get on board with and i should
not get so um frustrated around in the
first place so i think this is
definitely something that i love so it's
for sure a plus point on this topic so
let's go into the books number one is
the book attached and i read this very
recently i've been avoiding this book
for a while because i thought well you
know i know what it says i'm very
interested in kind of child development
and child psychology so i knew about the
attachment theory in babies but reading
this book it really helped it was the
exact same thing but as applied to
adults this is a book that i would
basically recommend to anyone who has
ever been wants to be or is or is
interested in romantic relationships
because it really really really really
really helps with giving you a framework
of approaching your own internal state
and the behaviors of your partner
potentially so what this book does is
that it divides people into three groups
secure attached and avoidant it has a
lot of questions and descriptions around
each of these different types so you can
identify with which one you resonate the
most now or with which one you've
potentially resonated most in the past
and also it describes the interactions
between them which ones are healthier
and unhealthier and what sort of
maladaptive behaviors can be triggered
when different combinations or
situations happen so it is a bit of a
rigid framework which again i would take
with a pinch of salt because of course
we're all different we all vary between
these different types and
there's no such formula as to what kind
of person you are or personality you are
in my opinion but i think that it's very
very helpful in giving that language and
framework for understanding each other
and especially analyzing yourself and
perhaps the very irrational ways that
you may have behaved in the past in your
relationships so 100 would recommend
this book the next book i would
definitely recommend is rip it up and on
the surface i'm going to describe this
book it literally sounds like one of the
books that i would have absolutely hated
before but honestly it's very very well
written basically i would recommend this
book to anyone who feels slightly
anxious or introverted or kind of
too complicated and as though they can't
fit in with others and they're as though
they're not as happy and lighthearted as
everyone else is around them because it
really really really really helps for
that the main premise of the book is the
as-if principle which basically means
that it's not our feelings that guide
our actions but our actions that guide
our feelings which means that we do
things and then we interpret that as a
feeling rather than we feel something
and that's the truth and then we behave
a certain way it talks about small
things that you can do for example how
laughter can make your day feel a lot
better rather than a gratitude journal
or things like this so it gives you
small tips about life but also it really
shows you how fluid things like
confidence and love and happiness and
self-respect are and how much these
things can actually change and be
influenced by things around us which on
one hand can sound scary but on the
other hand also means that they're not
set in stone so wherever you feel right
now does not need to be the state that
you have to be in forever and there are
small changes and small shifts in your
perspective that you can do to really
create a huge difference in your life so
i would really really really recommend
this one the next book i would really
recommend to anyone who like me in the
past strongly hated self-help books
because this is borderline philosophy
and very little self-help but it's
really really good the book is called a
new earth and i don't know if you know
alan watts but it's very similar to his
sort of philosophy gives me a strong
sense of a heavy influence of eastern
philosophy in it and basically what this
book can give you is a sense of
immediate peace i would definitely
recommend it if you are anxious or
worried about your life or where you
stand it won't tell you how to change
anything but it will make you
it will shift but it will make you shift
your whole perspective on where you
stand and what things around you look
like it is so so beautiful it's a very
gentle book that helps you navigate your
inner world while taking into
consideration those around you which i
think is quite rare in this sort of
genre it also helps you let go of your
ego and deal with the surrounding
pressures of the world which i think are
so acute in this day and age it feels
almost like an antidote to the modern
world of consumerism of stress of
pressure of desire of needs and wants
that are constantly shoved at us from
every direction and it kind of helps you
let the world and life flow through you
rather than frantically grasping at
things around you which can lead to a
lot of anxiety so i would definitely
recommend this one so much the next book
is my love hate book the courage to be
disliked hate how it's written hates a
lot of parts about it but having said
that it is a bit of a philosophical book
so in that sense it does take an extreme
position which i can appreciate but this
book really really helps shift your
perspective on your life and your
interactions with other people and the
main thing that i got from this book is
the distinction between my task and
other people's tasks or in a less nice
way my problem and other people's
problem in recognizing that the person
who will get the effect of whatever is
happening
is the person whose task this thing is
what that means for example is that
someone else's opinion on me is their
problem because their opinion on me will
not change anything about me and my life
i'm just continuing to do my thing but
it will change their internal experience
and their emotions and their thoughts so
it's their problem and i think it just
goes into so many details about where
your problems and the things you can
influence and the things you should be
worried and concerned and thinking about
and and where those of other people
begin because i feel that this line
between my task and someone else's task
is so so blurred and especially if
you're a people pleaser like me it gets
really pushed on the other end of me
taking on so much pointless
responsibilities about others state of
being when rather there is absolutely no
need this is almost futile and
unnecessary and support and help and
love does not come in the form of me
trying to control other people's
internal states of being and rather i
should be concerned with myself and
extend my help to others when i am calm
and able to do that which i will be able
to do much more often if i'm a bit more
in control or oh not controlled but if
i'm a bit more at peace with where i am
so 100 would recommend this book it's
really really great the last book is
personality isn't permanent and this is
a really great one it kind of treads the
line slightly onto toxic positivity but
with a grain of salt i think that is
acceptable and fine given the kind of
results that the book gives the book
talks a lot about your personality not
being set in stone and the small things
about you will change are changing and
have changed again and again and again
no matter your age no matter your stage
in life and it kind of gives you this
empowering acceptance around the fact
that no matter who you think you are you
will be changing with your life so you
might as well be slightly intentional in
the direction that your life goes for
example the people you're surrounded by
the challenges you choose to accept the
growth that you let happen or the growth
that you seek by yourself and you might
as well be a bit more intentional about
these things because we're all going to
change anyway we might as well go in a
direction that we want to go in so i
think this book is just kind of an
antidote for that sad thought of oh this
is who i am i don't like the person i am
but rather thinking you know we can make
small tweaks and changes to this i'm
absolutely fine but i can make myself
feel a bit better or a bit more at peace
with where i stand if you are like me
and you're actually quite picky about
the validity and the resources of
different studies that you are seeing
mentioned in books a great way to put
you in a position of being very
empowered and properly approaching these
is to have a strong foundation of
mathematics and science and the best way
that i love to learn this as an adult
who is no longer getting this in any
sort of formal education is by using
brilliant which are very kindly
sponsoring this video brilliant is a
stem sciences educational app and
there's so much you can learn on it but
the thing that i am laser focused on in
the moment is the probability and
statistics section which i still haven't
finished but i'm going through and
enjoying every moment of i cannot rave
enough about how easy the games make
studying these sort of topics it's super
helpful in re-establishing and also
helping you apply different sort of
mathematical skills and settings that
are genuinely useful in real life so if
you want to join me on this journey i'll
have a 20 discount code link to my
description or you can just click the
link to get a trial and see what i am
raving about because it is really really
helpful so yes those are five books that
were explicitly written with a goal of
improving my life that actually did feel
did improve my life so yeah i hope this
video was helpful in any shape or form i
would love to know any self-help books
that you like or even better any sort of
fiction books that you like that end up
being self-help i might do a video on
that actually why fiction books are so
much better than self-help books because
there's so many more fiction books that
i think have given me um a lot of
learning in life and a lot of pleasure
so if you made it to the end of this
video thank you you fellow nerd and i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day because yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye